i don't know if you heard or not but uh
possible exxon mobil chevron
merger the biggest merger of all time
the chief of executives exxon mobil and
chevron spoke about combining the oil
giants after the pandemic
shook the world last according to the
people familiar with the talks
testing the waters for what could have
been one of the largest corporate
mergers
of all time such a deal would reunite
the two largest
descendants of the john d rockefeller
standard oil company which was broken up
by the u.s regulators in 1911 and
reshaping the oil industry by the way fy
if
if rockefeller's wealth back in the days
before he died if you compare it today
with
inflation and everything to get you know
what his network 340 billion dollar net
worth
he'd be number one he'd be number one
right he'd be combined
that's right rockefeller was a
rockefeller
a combined company market value could
top 350 billion dollars exxon has a
market value of 190 billion dollars
while chevron 164. together they would
likely
form the world's second largest oil
company by market cap
production producing about 7 million
barrels of oil and gas
a day based on pre-pandemic levels
second only in both measures to
saudi or a ram code think about it
that's a pretty big number right there
so what do you
what are your thoughts about this one i
did a little research on this yeah and
number one i just how massive saudi
aramco is
uh 1.7 trillion dollar company i think
the only company that's big as them
is apple as far as um market share
um but here's here's actually something
pretty interesting you know who the
biggest company in the world was
in 2006 most highest valued company in
the world 2006 walmart
no who exxon exam okay okay so now we're
talking about them
um struggling so bad
that now they might potentially because
this is all just sort of hearsay
initial talks having to merge
with chevron just to compete in the
marketplace right now because under an
abide administration do you think
they're going to be pro
or against uh energy yeah and gas and
consumption 100 percent
i mean by i did an episode about you
know buying's going green i mean clean
energy
green jobs yep so this is all just
initial talks right now
whether exxon and chevron but you know
15 years ago
exxon was the big dog energy was the big
dog around the world
and now who are the big dogs tech apple
amazon obviously microsoft was there
then
um the
tech is now the big dogs around the
world and energy is clearly plummeting
well tesla as well they're making a big
tesla on the um
with all their solar and all that uh
electric tesla is tech big data
and clean energy not traditional correct
yeah big oil
you know exxon chevron that type of
energy yeah what are you getting a uh
a tesla when are you getting a when are
you getting a you know uh
electric car electric you know what i
said panamera electric
that car is pretty ridiculous we had the
i8 and that wasn't that i did have the
i8 and i love the i8 i don't know if
you've seen this what is that bmw i8 the
doors open up on this side
it's like uh pull it out mario i like
that i'm gonna pull it up did you drive
the ice yeah i
i drove to pick up your dad one time
yeah it was actually pretty good i mean
it wasn't really
that fast it was 16 like 3.5 seconds
four seconds
right there it was faster than my saturn
yeah it is faster than your saturn for
sure so the i8
uh uh you drove this for a while yeah
this is the electric bmw
yeah i had this for two years really
that's the one the white and the blue
right at a mission impossible it is it's
like it's a car it's a nice so you had
an electric car
it's right there that's exactly what i
had i had that one right there okay
i would charge it every day and what was
that like what was that life like
let me tell you i don't even know why i
got rid of this car why did i get rid of
this car
you ended up getting i think it was the
the orange lambo the aventador yeah
what well i got the uh i got the dog i
got the rolls out i don't know i got rid
of this car this was a phenomenal car
it's actually a very good car you know
i it was a very good everyday car is
what this was
very good everyday car and but you had
to charge it there was no gas stations
no you it's gas it was a combo gas it
was a hybrid it was gas
and electric so if i had the electric
great if i didn't i could get the gas as
well so can i answer your question on
the market
i kind of like that believe it or not i
kind of like that the hybrid approach
yeah i kind of like that because there
wasn't
enough chargers and i didn't have time
to go stand somewhere and wait for 15
minutes 20 minutes i'm like dude
how long does it take you to fill up
your tank yeah five minutes not even
whatever two minutes
how long does it take you to charge your
entire i don't even know how that's it's
a it's a while it's not like a minute or
five minute thing you got to sit there
for some time right so
something like this you go in and it's
hybrid or workout or some days i forgot
to charge
it i'm going to go to the gas station
and take care of that go ahead mario
yeah question for you a little
speculation just a question
we'll go a little deeper but the biz doc
did an episode last week i think on
tesla yeah we talked about maybe elon's
planning doing
energy gas stations do you think if on
these oil companies and they're thinking
next moves
strategically they're merging in order
to maybe take on the next big thing
do you think that could be a possibility
i think they're unified right now
because there's a lot of
enemies the next let's just say biden
and kamala go eight years
let's say a lot of people are saying
it's not gonna happen meaning kamala is
gonna be the face because biden may not
make it past four years health-wise we
don't know it's just pure speculation
but say they go eight years can you
imagine eight years of
anti-oil agenda non-stop you
have to pivot remember remember that one
episode we did about uh
general motors where tom put up the
picture saying
that general motors website even though
they only sell three percent of their
cars are electric
you know on their website the only car
they had on general motors website was a
seo standing next to their only electric
car
even though they only sell two to four
percent of electric cars their website
says what wow electric
cars and they said by 2025 i think
cadillac is going 100
uh 20 35 20 30 20 30 or some number i
don't know if it was 20 35 or 20 25
but it was in the next five days
basically in the next handful of years
they're going cadillac is going 100
electric so
this doesn't mean the cadillac or their
entire fleet it was cadillac only first
and then they're gm yes so if you if you
look at numbers exxon's share
fell 29 last year chevron fell 20
last year yeah okay the the the stock
index
of u.s oil and gas companies was down 57
at one point in 2020 you know you you
have to
also the the challenge with exxon and
chevron goes these guys thought oil was
going to be around forever
and they took a hit by the way these are
oil guys executives you know kind of
money they make
they go golfing two three times a week
making a million dollars two million
dollars half a million dollars
regular executives who are not even
working making that kind of money
because they think this is going to be
around forever
and unfortunately this happens in many
newspapers
radio oh are you kidding me of course
they're getting fat and lazy
you can't go like this forever and elon
musk is officially forcing
chevron and mobile exxon to get back to
work
and elon musk is forcing these guys
who've been kicking the golf in three
four five times a week
to get back to work because if you don't
your business model is no longer working
oh my god
today well i mean right here it says it
was um
was it exxon which was america's most
valuable company seven years ago this
isn't
a hundred years ago with a market share
of more than 400 billion nearly double
chevrons all right
exxon has fallen from its heights
following a series of strategic missteps
which were further exacerbated
by the pandemic we all remember back in
march oil went to
you know zero dollars a barrel right
what was going on right there
but here's the biggest point right here
it was removed from the dow jones
industrial average last year for the
first time
since it was added as standard oil in
1920
scary thought to be so 90 years ago it's
removed from
dow jones for the first time in 90 years
since 1928.
so that alone ought to tell you what
direction this is going to right now
this is this is not a joke like these
guys are
you know i don't know if they're sitting
there panicking right now but i think
they're saying listen man we know we
can't stand each other you're
you're exxon you're chevron look let's
just kind of team up we have a common
enemy
just come together and try to make this
work and be on the same team together
what do you say great so it's not going
to be that pretty but uh
it's not a bad move that they're making
so we'll see what's going to happen
there with this
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you